- I think I'm definitely
getting other people to read it
from now on,
this is like literally out
of all of the things I do
in my life this is my biggest struggle.
(laughter)
I hate it.
- This is the dentist,
I don't think anyone --
- Yeah, I hate the dentist.
- Fucking hate going to the dentist.
- I need to go, can you set me up?
Can we do the dentist doctor thing?
Can we like, really do
it once and for all?
- Yes.
- 'Cause when I do with rotten teeth
it's gonna be your fault.
(electronic music)
Uh, getting prepped for the keynote,
gonna give a talk on the
current state of opportunity
in the rest estate industry.
That's how I wanna name
the keynote, Babin.
Um, and uh, I'm excited about it.
Good vibes, Vegas, gonna
record my audiobook,
finish that off for all of you,
because I know all of you
are getting antsy, so.
- Gary, this is my wife Kelly.
- Kelly, such a pleasure
to meet you, how are you?
- Hi, nice to meet you.
Good, thank you.
- Awesome. Let's do it.
- You must be DRock.
- No, this is Babin, but
he gets that every day.
- Babin, alright, I'm
Adam, nice to meet you.
- But honestly that's my favorite moment,
you have to keep that in
the episode Babin, sorry.
DRock was so well-branded that,
it's actually Babin's two-year
anniversary with the team.
- You'll graduate to DRock status.
- That's right, one day,
Babin, you can be like BRock.
- You might be BRock at some point, right?
- He's about to kill
you, so let's move on.
It's only so much that you can listen
to somebody like me pound you
and you know you're wrong every time.
When I'm like, "Hey, stop
blaming somebody else,"
like when I literally create a framework
that is 100 percent accountability,
not because of anything else
other than I think it works,
like it leads to,
I think 100 percent
accountability leads to happiness.
If you think somebody
else is in control of you
you're losing.
If you think the President,
your parents' upbringing,
your debt, if you think something
is in control of you you're unhappy.
I don't think that, I
think I can move to Sweden.
I think I can get a divorce, I
think I can change my career.
I mean that, I mean that.
Like, I dunno, so, anyway,
a lot of people are navigating their lives
through using excuses to cope.
And then I come along
and I'm like, "Not true,"
and you're like "Eh."
- [Man With Back To Camera]
I need it to be true.
- I need it to be true,
"But you don't get it Gary,
my dad molested me."
Cool, comma, and?
A lot of people have been
molested unfortunately.
And like, a lot of them
have gone on to achieve.
Like, it's really kind of, it's difficult.
It's difficult when I'm
putting out content like
your problem's your mother.
And like, you're not doing things
because your mother didn't raise you well,
and you're pandering to her.
That's not consumable content,
then I curse, then I'm alpha,
so there's a lot of
reasons not to hang around,
but the good part is I
don't want everybody.
- Right, you can't bother for everybody.
- I want people who want to win.
And like, good things will
happen, I get my heart
off the e-mails I get every
day if something happened.
I mean, the guy on the escalator is like,
"You're the reason my
wife gets out of bed,
started getting out of bed."
Do you know what kind of impact that is?
That's far more exciting to
me than telling you exactly
how to plan a Facebook ad
on a white paper with a marker up there.
- [Man With Back To
Camera] It fuels your fire.
- 100 percent, 'cause
that's fucking real shit.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Thank you so much.
Thank you. Thank you.
Oh, I like your pink hair.
(cheering)
Ha ha, I'm always listening.
Good morning REMAX, how are you?
(cheering)
So impressed with this turnout,
because I was in Toronto yesterday
and I flew in pretty late,
and when I was walking
from check-in to my room
I saw a lot of you
getting very ridiculous.
(laughter)
I'm putting out podcast
every day and trying
to bring value, not
sell you into my funnel,
not get you to sign up for my thing,
and so I'm bringing value
thus I have his attention,
which is remarkably valuable.
Could be even the reason
I'm back, could be. I dunno.
Could, it is, I made a shitload of money
because of my podcast right?
I mean, you have to understand,
you have to understand,
right now there is nobody
dominating the top 200
in the real estate sector in podcast.
Everybody here has the chance tomorrow
to start a podcast that's evergreen.
What happens in real estate
which is what happens
in so many other industries is we default
into selling too much and
not enough into branding.
I love selling,
let me tell you the best
way to sell in the world.
Have the customer come to you
without you "doing anything".
You didn't buy your Nikes,
I would argue that everybody
in this audience right now
bought 85 to 90 percent
of the clothes they're wearing
right now because of brand,
not because of sales.
I need everybody to look at this.
Babin, where are you?
Get up here.
Actually you know what, stand, don't,
I know some of you are
tired, last night I saw you,
please keep standing, I need
to make a piece of content.
Give me one second, Babin, get over here.
Keep standing, please stand
if you mainly watch Netflix.
Instagram, guess, what,
all these people standing,
which is like 70 percent of the audience,
mainly only watch Netflix.
Are people really watching commercials?
(cheering)
Thank you, thank you so much, thank you.
- Oh my God.
- How are you?
- Pleasure to meet you.
- Thank you brotha.
I'm one of them cheering
and screaming out there,
I'm one of the younger guys
over here in the Portland area.
Just got started with
REMAX five months ago.
- Good luck to you brother.
- Closed five homes so far.
Got the drive, I already
know the man who's literally
putting out that podcast every day.
- I love it.
- I just want a picture with you.
- You got it, let's do it.
- I was just listening to
the thing you just posted
about you anniversary for
Wine Library and stuff,
and how you just went out had
your team pick up a camera,
sat down, showed that little clip of you
just making that first video.
And I just started doing
local videos, like in my,
and it just made me laugh so hard,
because my first video is me just sitting,
looking like a weirdo,
and it's the most worst
video I've ever made and --
- One step at a time.
That's awesome.
♪ You gettin' stuck I
see feet in the mud ♪
♪ You have been caught in the flood ♪
♪ While the water is imparted we run ♪
♪ Reap what you sow, the harvest is lust ♪
♪ You have been enjoying life ♪
♪ Sipping the syrup and lining the white ♪
♪ Takin' whatever you judge disorder ♪
♪ The wicked is covered in blood ♪
- Ain't nobody.
(pop song playing)
Hello man, do you know what page we're on?
- [Woman In White Shirt]
Yesterday um, Lance told me
we start at 116.
- Did you just see what you did?
- Yeah.
- You literally just drilled
that bro, that was so weird.
- Greg, can you talk to
him while I'm in here?
- There's something you should know.
Right this minute I have around 500 DMs
from people who want something from me.
You know what I have to say to them?
Mazel tov, and go away, and
that's if I'm in a good mood.
Or I'm trying to be nice.
Why would I encourage you
to try to get other influencers' attention
when I ignore or reject
the majority of people
who try this tactic with me?
Because if they were doing it
right, I wouldn't reject them.
If I felt they weren't
just trying to use me,
if I thought they were just
genuinely trying to be helpful,
if they could recognize
a hole in my business
and the knowledge,
if they could recognize
a hole in my business
and had the knowledge
and skills to fill it,
I might consider talking to them.
When you can't offer exposure
or money, what do you have?
Knowledge and skill.
Do you own a pizza shop?
Could you offer free pizza
from your shop for six months?
Are you a graphic designer?
Could you offer to make
600 custom filters?
Do you own a liquor store?
As soon as your targets
post shots of themselves enjoying wine,
you could direct message them
with an offer for a free
case of wine for the month
or for the rest of the year,
P.S. New Jersey laws don't
allow this, but other states do.
Otherwise I'd be doing this
with my family business.
People will tell you not
to sell yourself cheap,
but you can stand on that principle only
when you have people willing
to buy what you are selling.
For a perfect example
of how to do his right,
read DRock's story in
chapter three of my book,
"Ask Gary V," or you can hear his version
of the story in my Medium piece
"How I Got My Job For Gary Vaynerchuk".
♪ You gettin' stuck I
see feet in the mud ♪
♪ You have been caught in the flood ♪
♪ While the water is imparted we run ♪
♪ Reap what you sow, the harvest is lust ♪
♪ You have been enjoying life ♪
♪ Sipping the syrup and lining the white ♪
♪ Takin' whatever you judge disorder ♪
♪ The wicked is covered in blood ♪
♪ Welcome to the city of the nonsense ♪
♪ Pleasure is the peace we confide in ♪
♪ Dive in, ride a shotgun ♪